[Musik]
hallo herzlich willkommen zu salehs welt
heute gibt es ein richtig tolles rezept
ich werde nämlich einen italien bürger
machen und was passt besser zu einem
italien burger als italienischer käse
ich habe hier einen gramer pagano dem
kennt ihr auch wahrscheinlich der grappa
dame wurde von menschen entwickelt und
erfunden
die einfach ihre milch haltbar machen
wollten und grammer heißt einfach nur
krümel käse und pagano bezeichnet
einfach nur den käse
das ist ein adjektiv dafür dass halt der
käse nördlich der poebene stammt in
italien und deswegen darf mit dieser
käse so bezeichnet werden
was macht den käse so besonders er
schmeckt sehr fein und aromatisch und er
hat weniger fettanteil das heißt der
käse ist auch schon nach neun monaten
reifen er kann aber auch über 20 monate
reifen und dann an aroma und intensität
gewinnen
ich verwende den these heute zum einen
für meine bürger bank ich werde mama
papa und chips machen und dann werde ich
nach ofenkartoffeln mit kramer partner
zu bereiten ich werde jetzt aber zuerst
einmal die burger bands machen und
deswegen zeigen sich mal die zutaten mit
dem hefeteig wendig einen würfel hefe 30
gramm zucker 30 gramm zuckerrübensirup
200 milliliter lauwarmes wasser 260 km
ein kilo mehl vier teelöffel salz 200
gramm getrocknete tomaten und 160 gramm
flüssige butter schließt jetzt zuerst
einmal die hefe im warmen wasser auf
kommt die vermischung in der große
rührschüssel gebe ich da den zucker dazu
sogar ein sirup
so könnt ihr zum beispiel auch nicht
verwenden dann das mir er hat gedacht es
kommt dann eben mutter mit
das salz und die eier und auch die
flüssige butter und dann kann ich daraus
einen geschmeidigen hefeteig nähten und
schon mal hier die getrockneten tomaten
klein schneiden
das waren die die in öl eingelegt sind
das öl habe ich einfach im glas gelassen
das kann ich weiter verwenden und diese
jetzt einfach klein schneiden und mit
dazu geben
[Musik]
jetzt sieht der hefeteig super aus und
ich werde ihn jetzt geschmacklich noch
verfeinern und dafür nehme ich jetzt
gerade mal verbannung etwa 200 gramm
dann können wir einfach so abstechen und
damit der käse fein gerieben und der
passt dann geschmacklich wirklich
wunderbar zu den bürger bands dann
schmeckt ja so ein bisschen kräftig und
gibt einfach eine schöne reaktion tolle
sachen gemacht
[Musik]
der hefeteig fertig jetzt kann ich
einfach ein bisschen öl nehmen
daneben das festival von den
getrockneten tomaten und bestreicht eine
arbeitsfläche jetzt sind teil kurz
durchkneten und zu einer kugel formen
und das restliche öl gebe ich einfach in
die rücksitze kann den teig den rhein
legen und dann abgedeckt für ungefähr
eine stunde aufgehen lassen und die zeit
nutze ich jetzt um schon mal das fleisch
vorzubereiten
[Musik]
ich habe jetzt die eigentliche
rindfleisch und zwar in den akten
genommen und wolf dasselbe hierdurch und
ihr braucht etwa 120 gramm pro bürger
das heißt je nachdem wie viele bürger
machen möchte so viel hackfleisch
braucht ihr dann uns macht hackfleisch
immer gerne selber weil ich so einfach
weiß was drin steckt so kann ich den
fettgehalt selber bestimmen und kann
einfach auf gute fleischqualität achten
[Musik]
das habe ich das hackfleisch gut
durchgeknetet jetzt nämlich immer 150
gramm portionen und die kommunizierende
burger presse und werden dann zu betis
geformt
[Musik]
und burger pettys die wird sich
tatsächlich immer gar nicht sondern
benutze dann die soße und dem bürger an
sich und den belag als würze und las
hier wirklich den reinen rindfleisch
geschmack und das wichtigste an dem
pettys ist eigentlich nur dass man sie
nach dem vormund 14 pause auf dem grill
kommen
[Musik]
jetzt kann ich die brötchen formen und
zwar nehme ich jetzt den teig und
halbieren erstmal entweder könnt ihr die
brötchen so formen wie in meinem burger
bands video also wirklich schöneberger
bank rund ich habe jetzt aber er die
idee dass wir sie ein bisschen dreckig
machen so dass es so ein bisschen
optisch an schabbat appold ihn erinnern
das heißt der teig wird jetzt auch eckig
ausgerollt nicht zu dünn
[Musik]
jetzt nehmen die entweder messer oder
eine pizza rat ich nehme jetzt einfach
das etikett und schneider jetzt die
brötchen zu beschneiden und jetzt
einfach
[Musik]
und schlägt die jetzt mit der mehligen
seite nach oben direkt auf eine back
folie aufs parkett
so bekommen sie beim backen so ein
bisschen diese mehlige oberfläche
[Musik]
und die habe ich noch ein paar type
reste daraus mache ich einfach kristin i
ich nehme ein bisschen olivenöl auf
meine arbeit platte die 90 diese teig
reste formen sie zu einem langen strang
und wenn szenen olivenöl und dann kommt
der glarner pagano drauf und sie können
dann als treibstoff ofen gebacken werden
[Musik]
die burger brötchen werden jetzt noch
abgedeckt wir dürfen noch mal etwa eine
viertelstunde auf gehen ich kann aber
schon mal die christine fertig machen
ich nehme jetzt hier noch ein bisschen
kleiner pagano streue den trüber und
kann die schon mal backen und danach
werden die bürger brötchen auch mit
kramer pendant bericht heute und im ofen
gebacken und wenn ich sie richtig lecker
luftig haben wollt dann könnt ihr zum
beispiel noch die dampf stoß funktion an
machen oder einfach im schälchen mit
wasser in den backofen mit rein stellen
[Musik]
so sehen jetzt die frisch gebackenen
brötchen auf diese nicht richtig gut aus
vor allem sind sie super jetzt denke ich
die ab lasst ihr abkühlen und werde
jetzt schon mal die soße herstellen das
war noch ein bisschen heißt und zeigt
euch mal die zutaten für die mayonnaise
für die mayonnaise verwende ich drei
frische eigelbe den saft von eineinhalb
betonen eineinhalb teelöffel salz etwas
pfeffer und 300 milliliter
sonnenblumenöl für die arrabiata
variante verwende ich 30 com tomatenmark
einen teelöffel chili und für die grüne
pesto variante nämlich eine
knoblauchzehe und 50 gramm
basilikumblätter er sich zuerst mal den
zitronensaft aus für die mayonnaise
braucht man nämlich immer ein bisschen
sollte endlich könnt ihr auch nehmen
aber ich bin es mit sich und sagt immer
leckere und die eier müssen wirklich
ganz frisch sein
also dann ist er wirklich drauf achten
[Musik]
ich weiß ich jetzt nicht traut die
mayonnaise selber zu machen kann
natürlich auch fertig gekaufte
mayonnaise verwenden und die dann weiter
verwandeln in pasto marinese und in
tomatenmark arrabiata mayonnaise hier
gebe ich jetzt noch das salz dazu und
ein selber und verrührt die zutaten
[Musik]
hier kommt jetzt noch ein treffer dazu
und jetzt wenn die eier masse dann ganz
die creme sitcom das ist so und hier ist
einfach nur ganz so wie sieht das bild
ganz langsam zuzufügen
damit dieses geld mit dem öl verbinden
kann da muss man schon ein bisschen
gedulden
[Musik]
so sieht jetzt die mayonnaise aus und
ich habe ihr ziel bereits den knoblauch
und dem publikum zerkleinert jetzt
drittel ich die mayonnaise das heißt ein
teil der tel
der andere teil wird grün und der andere
wird
[Musik]
und mayonnaise arrabiata mit chili und
tomatenmark
[Musik]
die mayonnaise werde ich jetzt abdecken
und dann in den kühlschrank stellen
was jetzt noch fehlt sind die krahner
pagano chips dafür habe ich den graner
pagano setzte dann kleine häufchen auf
ein backpapier und bugs im backofen
münsterkäse und nach dem abkühlen werden
die chips dann richtig schön kross und
knusprig bevor ich jetzt die pettys
grille werde ich noch die ofenkartoffeln
vorbereiten da gibt es bereits ein
rezept auf meinem kanal und dann kann
ich nämlich wenn die im ofen sind die
bürger grillen und belegen und dann ist
alles rechtzeitig fertig
[Musik]
jetzt geht's ans grill ich werde cdp
dies noch mit öl bestreichen und kann
sie dann direkt in der pfanne oder auf
seiner grillplatte grillen einfach von
beiden seiten bis die per gesten schöne
kruste haben
[Musik]
ich habe schon einen riesenhunger und
hier drinnen riecht einfach super lecker
ich habe jetzt hier noch pinienkerne an
größte die griechen hier lag das fleisch
die bürgerkammer pagano alles perfekt
wenn ihr möchtet könnt ihr die bürger
partie ist jetzt gerne auch nochmal
rösten und posten gerne auch auf dieser
grillplatte aber ich habe sie heute
frisch gebacken und ich lasse es einfach
so dann gebe ich dir jetzt bis zum mars
von meiner arrabiata neue drauf das weiß
morath wartet schon auf den startschuss
dann gebe ich da jetzt bisschen von
meiner pastor mayonnaise drauf
[Musik]
rucola rote zwiebeln
kramer pagano cracker
und da nehme ich einfach noch ein
bisschen was von der mayonnaise hier
aufs brötchen wenigen kenne ich glaube
jetzt habe ich alles murat das ist die
italian burger mit den open kartoffeln
mit kramer planung und drei
verschiedenen decks und was sagst du
jetzt mal allein nur die zutaten
anschaut jetzt mal ohne spaß ich glaube
man kann sich keinen hochwertigen bürger
vorstellen was jetzt kosten wenn wir das
jetzt noch kaufen würde bis 120 euro
oder 25 euro
aber das ist genial zu tun 30 weil mit
liebe gemacht wir haben also ich nehme
mal besser kann man mit den bürgern
nicht mehr machen oder
ich glaube also welche zutaten definitiv
nicht vom geschmack her probiere ich
jetzt ganz ehrlich sagen ich freue mich
schon seit zwei tagen auf diesen moment
weil ich immer an diesem käselaibe
vorbei laufe ja dann sprecht mir
irgendwas raus und er ist die ganze zeit
okay sie auch und das werk an den
tischen durch natürlich immer kühl und
eingepackt aber der liegt hier und jeder
kommt hierbei unterricht sich der raum
sagt willig der wahnsinn und nur so ein
käse lang zu hause zu haben was
gigantisch ist übrigens von einer
freundin geschenkt bekommen und jetzt
werden wir dann große stücke raus
brechen die dann an unsere freunde
familie alle teammitglieder an alle
verteilen nudeln aus dem aus dem leib
richtig genial weil es diese polypen
sind 33 in altlußheim ist ein italiener
okay natürlich mit dem handy nicht
vergessen er hinzu in den zwei
enkelkinder
eigentlich lieben alle italiener roberto
dabei mir die fliesen gelegt den leben
nehmen jetzt kommt probier alle warten
auf den moment und hier sind übrigens
noch die christine hier sind die
christine die habe ich aus den teig
kräften gemacht richtig schön kross die
gucken ich probiert
ohne spaß vielleicht irgendjemand zukauf
von mcdonald's macht man solche bürger
dann läuft es bei euch echt wahnsinn
wahnsinn das ist der genialste berger wo
ich jemals vergessen habe ich wirklich
lieber mcdonald's lieber hans im glück
macht diesen cranach pagano bürger in
ihre filialen das durch die decke gehen
wirklich wie stärker partnership harmon
und ihr diesen burger nach machen
möchtest dann schaut auf meinem blog
vorbei - blog.de verwendet auf jeden
fall dieser herr steckt hier unten da
will ich alle eure beiträge sehen und
ich wünsche euch ganz ganz viel spaß und
nachbacken probiert den burger auf jeden
fall mal aus die ofenkartoffeln
natürlich auch und ich wünsche euch
einen guten appetit
hier der erste der mir diesen bürger als
bild schicke dem schicken kochbuch zu
die erste person die mir ein bildschirm
wie sie das ding gemacht hat aber auch
regional getragene getreu der stetigen
kochbuch zu werden das müsst ihr erst
ausprobieren es ging ja wirklich das
echte meisterwerke wo ich jemals
gegessen habe
[Musik]
vor den käse hatte ich jetzt mein papa
er hat den ganzen kram apa da nur hier
ausgelöst und jetzt aus dem rest hier
machen wir jetzt spaghetti aus dem grab
an
die habe ich schon abgekocht die werden
jetzt abgegossen und dann kommen die
direkt hier rein machen eine
riesenportion fürs ganze team ist
einfach mit vista darin schwenken und
dann können alle probleme menschen vom
rand könnte einfach noch ein bisschen
käse raus katzen
wer möchte gibt jetzt hier noch in
schuss olivenöl dazu oder auch bisschen
treffen sollte habe ich genau richtig
zum richtigen zeitpunkt die kommune
naja ich hab das gerochen ich liebe
spaghetti aus dem käse meint wirklich
die jungs können auch kommen nämlich
rein jetzt treffe okay noch trübe sogar
noch darüber
dann wurde es nicht kaufen du warst ich
hätte für euch gekauft
[Musik]